j'ai mes qualités chers collègues
l'ampleur des problèmes auxquels le mann
heat a été confronté en 2020 absolument
sans précédent
l'épidémie de colonna bérus et le
confinement généralisée et le gel d'une
partie de l'activité de l'activité
économique a suscité des transformations
majeures et des problèmes que l'économie
mondiale n'avait jamais connu depuis la
grande dépression
la pandémie a déjà tué des centaines de
milliers de personnes et des millions de
personnes se sont retrouvées sans emploi
et le risque principal aujourd'hui c'est
malgré certains signaux positifs
aujourd'hui on voit que ce risque
demeure des c'est un risque de chômage
massif et aujourd'hui on voit que ces
problèmes économiques se maintiennent et
le rôle du g20 consiste justement à
éviter
la diffusion de ce problème et l'arabie
saoudite en tant que membre président du
g20 a attiré notre attention là dessus
et donc notre attention va était
justement fixée sur les questions de
protection de la santé publique et de
trouver des réponses à aux menaces
aujourd'hui et dans le passé le g20 déjà
avait déjà lancé des mesures pour réagir
donc aujourd'hui il faut l établir
l'activité économique et l'ensemble des
institutions économique mondiale au sein
de l'onu au sein de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé et d'autres
organismes
donc nos pays ont mis en place un
certain nombre de mesures stimulantes
qui représente à peu près 20 milliards
de dollars
et donc c'est une contribution
importante des dons qu'on a vu que si
l'économie se restaurent aux états unis
à ce moment-là l'économie dans
l'ensemble du monde pourrait continuer à
travailler donc on a vu que des
milliards de dollars ont été attribués
affectés à la restauration de l'activité
de la santé publique et la russie comme
d'autres pays a elle aussi d'autres pris
des mesures très importantes en mettant
comme pierre de touche aujourd'hui comme
valeur principale la vie et la santé de
la population et pour assurer cette
stabilité sociale le gouvernement russe
avec l'aide de la banque centrale a mis
en place un plan d'ensemble dead à la
population aux pme et aux en particulier
aux secteurs qui ont été
face à ce risque importante donc à
travers les budgets régionaux des aides
ont été proposées et l'ensemble de cette
cet ensemble de mesures représentent 4
5% 2 du pib du pays
donc renforcer le système de santé
publique pour éviter les pertes trop
forte et le financement des mesures que
nous avons prises nous a permis de
stabiliser un petit peu et de l'utiliser
à bon escient de nos réserves et un
certain nombre des pays et notamment
depuis économies émergentes n'ont pas
forcément trouvé les ressources
nécessaires
d'abord parce que les rentrées fiscales
ont baissé et les dépenses augmentent
chaque jour est donc là il ya un risque
de dévaluation pour les monnaies
nationales et les dettes souveraines
donc les deux tiers des empreintes qui
ont été faits se sont fait en dollar
hélas la banque mondiale et le fmi ont
apporté une aide importante et sur leur
proposition les il a été décidé au sein
du g20 de mettre de place un moratoire
sur
les remboursements des dettes des états
cela concerne au premier chef les pays
les plus pauvres et notamment vis-à-vis
des créditeurs des créditeurs privés et
je pense qu'il faut des mesures
supplémentaires pour éviter une
aggravation de cette situation et limite
et réduire les inégalités qui se sont
instaurées il ya aussi des mesures à
prendre dans le domaine du rock des
échanges commerciaux internationaux
il faut pouvoir restaurer les systèmes
de d'approvisionnement commerciaux
classiques s'adapter aux règles
multilatérales qui ont été mises en
place donc beaucoup de choses doivent
être dressé et donc on a une nouvelle
réalité économique est je pense le jeu
20 justement doit réfléchir à une
réforme de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce
face au débit aux défis qui se posent
aujourd'hui en s'appuyant sur en
s'appuyant sur des principes
universellement reconnus aujourd'hui
nous savons bien que nous n'avons pas
d'alternative à l'organisation mondiale
de commerce et la russie soutient
parfaitement le projet de réforme qui a
été proposée aujourd'hui et notamment
aussi en matière de vaccins pour que ces
vaccins qui se font l'objet de
recherches aujourd'hui peut-être puisse
être accessible à toute la population de
la terre est notre russie notre pays la
russie est tout à fait prête à
participer à ces travaux d'élaboration
de vaccins notamment notre vaccin foot
ligue et qui a été le premier à mettre à
être mis sur le marché
dans le monde et c'est pareil à nouveau
subir ce qui a été mis au point un
deuxième vaccin 3e et sur le plein point
d'être validé actuellement donc nous
avons mis toutes les ressources
possibles ici parce que notre objectif
commun est d'assurer pour l'ensemble de
la population de la terre une protection
sûre et fiable et là nous avons du
travail
effectivement pour tous et bien sûr il y
aura une concurrence qui est inévitable
mais je pense qu'il faut pas se partir
de principes humanitaires et c'est la
pierre de touche de notre démarche
je soutiens que la nécessité la
nécessité aujourd'hui d'utiliser ce
crise pour préserver notre environnement
travailler dans des conditions égales et
améliorer les mécanismes de coopération
internationale à travers les
institutions internationales telles que
l'onu qui font partie des institutions
reconnues mondialement et en s'appuyant
sur le respect du droit international et
c'est ainsi que nous pouvons répondre
ensemble aux défis qui se présentent
aujourd'hui chers collègues encore une
fois je remercie les organisateurs de
cette réunion d'aujourd'hui à se voir
l'arabie saoudite et je vous remercie